você pode até tentar e esquecer um pouco
mais algo não te deixa parte do passado
cobra de um futuro que faz refletir a
vida de põe na balança a escolha sua do
meio fio tem que escolher entre a
calçada ea rua e perguntou quem é aliado
nesta guerra mesmo alguém que pune a tua
atmosfera e acaba descobrindo que meu
inimigo é aliada de jogo para baixo
porque é de lá que se começam acontece
mas fita e os problemas se multiplica e
o ibge explica que só falta de interesse
não ser a culpada dilma então corre
ocorre o universo se move separado meio
do caminho no campo errado de escola
então prove que o certo existe beleza
descobre que é como remar contra a
correnteza
ok até se até o chão vá amanhece pois
ela quer decência cai julgamento
é isso que eu quero mas se fosse para
dar uma nota seria abaixo de zero e o
aborto frio não te amo banalizado beijo
gelado da morte que leva o italiano
cabelo hoje além do horizonte mas foi
mesmo talvez só assim a parte encontra a
irmã a pauladas caminhada a gente escuta
casa fita mano tá ligado
era mais ou menos assim
quem ainda fosse um jogo de neve cheio
de o meu recorde batendo no topo mas tem
uma vida eo meu corpo cansa ea cada dia
só que se renova e minha esperança tia
perguntou o menino que se finou 6 nada
só no curto escutar de bananeira correu
pouco apodreceu alma subiu então eu vejo
problema em fazer minha própria
decoração gilson perdão pela arrogância
cada resposta é destinada sua ignorância
e na favela continuar matando ficou tudo
isso você só enxerga até onde alcança
igreja que liberta mesmo preço do
contrato uma pena aí essa história
repetida sabe o que eu queria mesmo
depois do trauma resolvi me libertar em
cima do partido ak liberdade é essa que
ninguém entende todo elaborado xingu
pitt se prende mas não só ofende passe
novata crimes em cadência posso dizer
hoje que a poesia lírica coração com o
crime
são sons bert ely definir antes rose
meu medo que essa dor no peito seja a
cor que guardado até hoje aí aí moda que
pode acompanhar uma mega senha do bari
set jogado colégio tenta acompanhar a
idéia da companhia é ó obrigado por
fazer do meu show até hoje eu quero
saber onde um morador de evasão lutou na
missão lusa o autor fora roubado a
tensão pressão brasileira passando de
fase por bilhetes é poderoso e sabe
atacar deixando a verdade como na laje
balaku nas páginas de treme treme do
tema da paz e que tudo acabe falte o
ativo da rima jogado na pista aí não vão
me calar
adorador para morrer mas já avisa que
apesar de negócios à parte parte a prova
de escala de empate mas o que é que está
a cura da aids e tempos modernos antigas
cantigas negócio da china é fazer
medicina de à tona vai viajar todo o
clima quanto o sistema quebrando-o a
prima de título na cor diferente nos
olhos muito de cheiros 14 jogos por ter
um castelo gera destroços
pelo trabalho o golpe manter o foco o
estudo o pacote logo na bunda e deixei
vários portes é o preconceito é contra
os preconceituosos citou bem na foto
isso não importa de volta na pista goa
na roda a prisão das horas a caixa que
toca não tem pai que era o leque cola
não já a escola garante o baixo
completou 18 ficou muito louco cheio do
douro ficou muito alegre assassinos em
série a escola em greve o governo só
ganha o jogo sujo professor levando sua
de alunos e vai pra rua comprar é
chamado de vagabundo sair brigado lá vem
a xuxa
hum
ei continuarão ativos
eis onsong teste já é e
agora falar de um tema que é muito
importante a mulher eo cunhado
muitas vezes a esquecer o homem com vida
das comunidades quanto nas escolas de
todo tipo de centro comunitário um tema
que há pouco debatidos a bibi quando a
gente tem que falar às investidas de
coisas
veja também flamengo
colonizadores porque não ficaram da
minha vida era feliz até o seu povo
checar trouxeram repressão muita dor e
violência e meu povo saudável contaminou
de doenças regime em 500 existem caras
de pau quem descobriu o brasil que foi o
cabral otto escravidão devastou a minha
ciência tua exploração abafou a
subsistência são a resistência mesmo
sendo difícil no solo sagrado não quero
ter um gênio silvio nem tua cultura
catequese jesuíta deus tupã é o sopro
vida luz divina acabou matando o que dá
uma escolha então levaram o ouro da
terra porque vou trabalhar sei o que
quero com rendimentos em prática quando
você chegar nós aqui a sociedade de paz
uma taxa que também o povo nativo não
quero agarrar me deixem passar e onde tá
funai quando preciso no canto com
estratégica para a boca e ficar rico em
sua moda do século 21 fazemos nos
satisfeitos com o urucum desenhamos
façamos nossa própria identidade e
convivemos plantar do que um homem na
cidade mostram que a inclusão ainda a
favor quero ver os caiu mas com nível
superior se não somos valorizados pela
seleção pataxó
mas o canto sagrado com a leblon um
absurdo vieram tomaram o que é meu
o verde amarelo com um padrão europeu
antropofagia a efeito por polícia que
arrasta o meu corpo no asfalto da
carniça na teoria o patrimônio da nação
na prática o que fazem como essa isso a
som deu
quero os meus direitos e do personagem
que tratem nosso valor e nossa história
valorizando nossas raízes culturais e
que nunca especial nosso trajecto de
glória tem que ser essa caixa saiu sus
não é
antes de chegar em nova andradina o pajé
nosso maior trunfo landeiro enfermeiro
guerreiro agora pega capacita continuou
a fuga e garrafadas luxo peito do menino
cabril já de volta muito mais eficaz que
estão mazzeo acho que havendo chama
contato espiritual a medicina tumaco
cultura tradicional 19 de abril disso já
tô cansado criança vai pra escola e
voltar orientado sem saber o significado
varonil gostou do dia a dia de quem
descobriu o brasil
rasgar a história do colón do cortejo e
fica com a saga que eu contei pra vocês
faz barulho para tvs e aí faz barulho
boa tarde eu sou o pelé do manifesto e
começa a cantar eu sou chato pra caramba
eu vou falar um pouquinho aqui gostei
muito do que devam falou aqui na frente
sobre quando todo mundo diz acreditou
nele saca tu é doido não vai dar certo é
mais ou menos isso que aconteceu com a
gente
vocês estão fazendo aqui em belém
cantando rap samba música brincamos que
os estados unidos só dá certo em são
paulo vocês são loucos
e a gente já tá por exemplo já 18 anos
aí o hepta e a5 o kota 34 ea gente já
rodou e oeste ro do país fazendo o que a
gente gosta acreditando como edvan
também falou aqui a apesar de vocês e
ribeirinho apesar de você ser aquilo não
foi isso que expirou ele
a c&a fazer o que ele fez e é isso que
me inspira não porque eu sou pobre é
porque eu sou preto que eu não posso
fazer uma coisa é isso que me inspira
cantar relatar sobre o que eu vivo na
periferia
é antes de começar a cantar minhas
músicas eu sempre faço uva os diversos
vinhos da capela que é pra prender a
atenção do público eu tava lá em
brasília no passado escrevi essa música
é mais ou menos assim parado olhei a
vida passando pela cabeça lembrando da
cremação em cada canto que eu conheça
sorriso palma agito calma eles tocam no
carro meu sonho é tocar na alma a uma
reluzente meio à escuridão e libertando
as mentes da nova escravidão eu trago na
caneta bem muito mais que tinta repasso
para o papel todo o amor que há uma
cinta corre de vagabundo na luta contra
o mundo que diz que a culpa é nossa que
vê preconceito em tudo que com só uma
tem que comer a alma tem tantos para
destruir mas quantos para fazer o bem e
me cingir brincadeira o rap não é
disputa não importa o que você faça não
interfere minha conduta no peito a
esperança mistura com a agonia porque
nas mortes meu povo ainda é maioria
sacou que nos sentir nem dá para
decifrar sair pra dar um rolê sem saber
se vai voltar família amo vocês desse
meu jeito tosco que com sua alma tem a
minha é preto fosco grafitando as vielas
e os becos da favela pois não é nas
paredes as mentes são minha tela e se
vierem me mintam cancele os preto você
para sempre nem que arranca a melamina
da minha pele
em relação sobre fazer aquilo que a
gente vive de eu escrevi essa música
para a minha irmã se chama alvorada é um
presente a professora vi que ela gosta
muito dessa música
eu escrevo sempre sobre aquilo que eu
vivo que eu observo na minha realidade
essa música uma busca muito forte
no dia 6 os ombros tops da guerra gies a
grão que tem corpo bonito mas tem a
beija flor linda daquelas que encantam
qualquer rapaz que tem várias curtidas e
músicas de imagem hoje esse som é pra
aquela filha ela que é magra mas nunca
sonhou passarelas e atriz de novela
tenha mais cobiçada sozinho no seu canto
varando a madrugada isolado e limita se
a poucas amizades não liga pra nenhum
padrão dessas 11 e tarde não tem roupa
de batata não liga pra etiqueta o cabelo
é vermelho sangue
a une é preta e fechando seu mundo seis
ongs credite-se de chico arremato
beatrice claíce o chamam de loucura
outros de depressão talvez ela só teja
cansada de 51 onde tanta podridão
farense vaidade é muita decadência prova
sociedade pessoas dupla-face juda sofreu
a beleza vai com tempo e ela já percebeu
o batom esmalte sombra cacau aqui a
gente cobre o rosto mas não esconde a
alma do copo vazio canta mente vazia é
toda vaidade do centro periferia garotas
seminua pra cima pra cima quer curtidas
no face para aumentar a autoestima rua
kospi pessoas pra lá e pra cá e ela tem
certeza que não é desse lugar também
divulga quem diria a gente observa
tantos trocando a por portaria e ela vai
em meio à multidão sozinha
buscando refúgio em algum livro ela
tinha um super herói que as ocorra e
atira gente mente de dentro destas o doi
corra corra menina se não tudo te tona
garotas pernas grossas transbordam
testosterona se abrigam pra ser igual
àquelas da tv parece o fim dos dias só a
gente que não vê gorda magra bonita e
feia quem é a presa e quem aranha nessa
teia urbano no plano e da decepção ea
cama sempre foi seu tempo de reflexão
qual é minha missão que eu estou fazendo
aqui que decisão tomar e qual o caminho
devo ir ela olha para as estrelas do
infinito é total uma feia dentro de cada
corpo bonito gorra menina corra fundo é
malvado em de sola mesmo com tanta gente
do teu lado e cada passo em busca da
felicidade de ser a banda pelo que é de
verdade não se enquadra nesses padrões
atuais
ou será que a gente que é normal demais
se veste igual e fala igual beleza gente
é feliz ao só como fã tristeza avareza
aparência vergonha os querem é bem mais
cultivo babilônia ser diferente um
constante incomoda e para ser visto tem
que seguir a moda os o cabelo e um
estilo pecado tal venda e aqui a gente
só compra de quilos ela quer um grande
amor sem ilusão não foi de sentimento e
meio a toda essa confusão caminho entre
o céu eo inferno e já virou rotina a
briga com seu demônio interno feliz
triste luta diária e ela vai peregrina
solitária e ela vai peregrina solitária
e ela vai peregrina solitária
ei ei som
eis a música da escola me inspirava
caramba só com a história de vida muito
boa verdade ó paí ó deus ó senhor
acredita que o homem só não entra em
contradição de um acreditar ônibus aqui
à disposição viração única tipo
respiração a voz só libera o que estava
dentro do coração ao chão minha canção
batinha família educou aí a rui cd busca
de disciplina foi longe cuidado existe
um samurai centro desse post busquei
exemplos e o encontrei um mês passado
firmamos próprias leis isso fez do time
o fogo de revolta apenas abriu os olhos
pra poder olhar em volta ouvir refletir
couro breve momento minha mãe morando de
favor
o atual momento eu me lembro o pequeno
nos seus braços sonolento meu pai do
cheiro o meu maior exemplo de com o
sonho conseguiu chegar em algo pra
conquistar a vitória teve que largar o
álbum divisor de baguá e produz banco
passado é passado hoje ele é vencedor na
carreira ele pensa sem o que o rabino
dov por nessa noite filho meu não morre
de fome do paço ultrapassa o limite da
pitty se repita correnteza que tem grana
seja on cola criou certo
pensando bem inspiração e acaba não
apenas o que ocorre é ocorre de cada um
que está aqui nessa sala presente hoje 7
tom e se soma o dedica cada ouvido certo
a cada visão
a gente é assim às vezes eu voto a idéia
é esse algo que eu quero salvar o mundo
mas me falta o capital em é o principal
depende da área mas possui ainda vai se
espalhar e com febre da malária eu sei
que vai a situação da hilária inspiração
é a sua luta diária enquanto tudo começa
bem no meu universo a poesia é o big ben
e dizem estrelas correm acabou
elas caíram e nasce mais um trabalhador
e hoje a caneta é meu guia passou aqui
reconhecer aquele que nem conhece a
maioria pesar do tipo mastodonte
inspiração única tirada de várias fontes
então descrever o momento
a letra mais consciente que te faz
gritar por dentro mestre de cerimônia
kit para refletir habilidoso igual
político admite libertando verdes
acorrentadas são brás da veia hospitais
maiores batalhas da levada louca da
quebrada acabei levando um pouco da rua
para dentro de casa
bibi dele gente e milliken narrados
falso e gosta tanto pote deputada já em
pc de inspiração do lotado para cada
irmão na madrugada tendo um bom
aprendizado ok ele essas além da
acadepol tenho com a aprendizagem é que
2 s
hum
estou vendo que vocês estão curtindo
muito legal bem solta black ciro edson
sá
a mãe sou favela soul rap soul aquele
que sejam esquece lei de casa bambam
piro disse é por uma batalha que chama
que são eu tiro
sou favela sou o rap soul aquele que
sirvam esquece leite cazaban piorou e se
é para uma batalha chama que sangue o
tirol o espelho da quebrada tem um lugar
quebrado e onde está ferido nas escolas
para a hbo
o exporta mas nada contra bout do
convento eu tenho uma carteira e 4 saca
disse preto
sangue suor de mais um capanga içando
treinamento louco pique rocky marciano
irritante a fonte estilo pra que corta
ela bata branca mas eu trago verso punk
pra quem não gosta só tua situação roupa
enxuga gelo então vale parron acha que a
revolução tanto a idéia de moleque eu
jurava de maternidades e volta tv
globinho a remando deixe de cinema cash
mas se que a rip rap procura o casulo
nation pega o que faz bem coloco o meu
trabalho e pra quem não gosta vai à casa
do ó
olha só que feio ele falou um palavrão
escasso pejorativo escuta informação eu
sempre quis mandar esse conselho pra
todo falso moralista que é pior do que
tenho nunca me limitei a um inimigo
palpites ou precipito betume a fronte de
madeirite em sala de aula nunca tive um
datashow mas hoje marca uma data que eu
venho e do show é muito divertido uma
rima improvisada semelhante à tiririca
quando contra uma filha da xuxa
meu peito o coração frio estaleiro e
cada peça que eu faço é bom se fosse o
primeiro
sou favela soul rap soul aquele que
serão esquece vem play de caça vampiros
vizinha por uma batalha me chama que
sangrou giró sou favela soul rap soul
aquele que citam esquece black caçapava
vampiro e se é para uma batalha de chuva
que segue o tirou do marajoara acabou
quilos em camaro é fácil mas acham que o
edifício matar montaram e quando tá
difícil a nutron cunha de aço total flex
criança na calçada sofri não esclarece
porque pais e responsáveis não usaram
juntas de ctec outra identifiquem de
toda a oposição espera bom dia gente
jesus cristo apanhou john lucich orienta
variação de hoje por tuma todo 40
sanduíche de presunto não vai surgir do
nada faz igual chave vai catar tuas
garrafa o mesmo ser humano que acha
linda borboleta esmaga uma tasca
proteína sheila morféia efeito que odeia
branco tem branco que odeia preto já não
vejo racismo nos pacotes de negresco
falha mas a vida chega mais do teu lado
além do seu carro de vidro peliculado a
vida bate como se fosse montar time
deixe o confronto cabuloso porque roupa
e feitio mas parada saco outras nem
tendo nunca joguei privado mas jogando
super nintendo
chega de mim hoje a favela que é cup
cake limpa tua cara e tira todo é
somente um estão presos no face porque
são feito em outros não são porque são
filhos do rei que você que nada sei
essa frase é muito louca humano que
disse isso sabia de muita coisa e se eu
nunca fui na tua palavra top não é
frescura minha respeito com hip hop
o vôo ou faz barulho pra ver te visse
obrigado
dá até vergonha de cantar fugir disso
mas você deve estar pensando lá vê lo de
novo esse papel é muito chato falando de
preconceito racial
mas a parada seguinte evita mais cedo
aqui tô com os cara chamado samba groove
então eu tocava músicas iam matar outro
menino preto era um menino e era preto é
beleza ele fizer essa música e falar um
pouco elétrons que escrever nada em cima
e tal tu bate tanto na questão do
preconceito racial
daí ele me contou a história que foi um
menino maranhão que foi acorrentado no
poste espancado até a morte
daí eu fiquei imaginando pô podia ser eu
então o que eu fiz eu escrevi um verso
mais ou menos assim o matar outro menino
preto era um menino e era preto matar
outro menino era um menino preto era o
menino podia ser um adulto podia ser o
pelé mesmo assim inventaria de luto pois
era preto do gueto sujeito suspeito
podia ser o seu filho sofrendo com
preconceito eu faço o som por mais que a
gente a pele não importa seu caráter se
ele sempre vou jogar do tom de pele que
é preto lindo como a noite nesta 6a
urbana minha alma traz lembranças do
açoite eu sou magia negra samba no pé da
moça
sou capoeiras o lado negro da força o
verso de castro alves o rima do mano
brown sua metade que nunca fez o ensino
fundamental só você saindo para
trabalhar pois até hoje nós somos
vítimas de um crime secular eu sou
garrincha mestre bielsa se pois o menino
preto lá podia ser o menino preto aqui
para algumas pessoas a palavra preto
significa uma coisa ruim
então quando elas queriam me xingar elas
me chamavam de preto como se isso fosse
uma ofensa
pelo contrário tenho orgulho de ser
preto quando eu era pequena as pessoas
falavam assim pra mim ó preto é [ __ ]
eu gostei da frase sabe
ei ei ei ei filho sim sobretudo com
muito amor daquele que olha no espelho e
acha fraga socorro ou nasci pra tá
chamando de gay de doutor
a biblioteca é votar cada irmão que
tocou tesouro aí o mundo é nosso pequeno
e eu quero é tudo como quem não quer
nada no sapatinho chegando de mansinho
você que eu não tô sozinho este plano
vai no jogo para não ficar pelo caminho
tem tudo que reluz é ouro parceiro
paraíso onde se ouve no navio negreiro a
rua e criou principalmente o ligeiro e
essa música é um alô pra todos que são
verdadeiros e duas vezes melhor não
cansei dessa parada
não sei dizer o preto do estilo homem na
estrada divertir atravessa a rua apa
voador de provar que o celular deu pra
não levar porrada pra frescura não me
diz aí quem consegue mas toda vez que
entrou no shopping segurança me segue
todo mundo percebe todo mundo repara que
a câmera me persegue a polícia sempre
para nuvem de cal dizendo que não há
preconceitos e acha que prevê la protegi
kilimanjaro feito é o xis da questão
ninguém explica direito porque a
descrição sempre bate quase um suspeito
sobre aquilo sim então preciso da fala e
chega de falar que o meu lugar na
senzala te calas i liga agora do rio
preto fala o cheiro da revolta
quilombola quis falar sei que você odeia
o estilo do gueto mas hoje vai ter que
fingir que gosta de preto e diz que acha
fota o meu cabelo duro diz que adora dos
panos grafite no muro mas de 4 condução
currículo na mão e essa área sempre
disse que eu não me encaixo do padrão
mas sem essa de patinho drake irmão eu
me mostrar com quantos rap se faz a
revolução sobretudo de uma franca não
que treta
se eu pudesse até a palma da minha mão
era preta que nem a tinta da caneta que
eu escrevi a minha letra orgulho terno
preto não guardado na gaveta é punir ute
pelos irmãos estou aqui a minha ppr mata
ver os pretos sorri
a estrutura rachar e esse império caiu
em uma nova era começou por cento e de
jesus o mundo todo vai saber da nossa
correria eu vim mostrar quanto jec se
consegue a corria e depois desse aqui é
o fim de tudo o que me incomoda
agora sim pode dizer que preto é [ __ ]
em ó ó professor nunca fui estudante não
tinha 11 na escola não funciona debaixo
da carteira
aí ó hoje está hoje
hoje acordei cedo com receio tão
praticada nas pilhas e olhei no espelho
a minha preguiça foi pelo ralo da pia
essa cara de maconheiros e respeito não
vou enganar contínuas até queria ter
informado na federal gastou à risca no
campo do ensino fundamental
que pressão quase em depressão tomando
banho e vou pensando na minha situação
enquanto me arrumo vou pensando como é
que tá na sala não encontra o meu
caderno pai cada calça meu tênis e
ricardinho só eu que acho tópico era e
só falta o uniforme vacilão correndo
pelo chão partido para chegar a tempo de
pegar a condução peguei o busão com
superlotação arregaço minha banda só pra
ver que horas sofrer tamanho do bolso e
pego da carteira que joga esqueci a
minha filha e contente paga esteira o
sistema não suporta viver dentro da
escola e mecânica na rua junto ao topo
uma série de tv é minha realidade graças
em sala de aula está na turma do chaves
no sistema não suporta viver dentro da
escola ele quer viver na rua junto ao
tubo de cola nas séries de tv
a minha realidade graça e sala de aula é
só na turma do chapéu escola nem sei
qual é o meu objetivo passa aviãozinho
com a folha do meu livro diretora vânia
assaly a galera se esconde ela não é o
felipão mas só convocou o meu nome que
requerem natural só me meter em confusão
com la em dia de prova da maloca do
fundão debaixo da carteira o papel faz o
passeio professor fica perdido e
conseguem tiroteio
a inspetora vai lançá lá pode descobrir
o perrengue só colar assumir mas acho
que o mister m na aula de inglês o que
se faz repetir todo ano estudando a
droga do verbo to be professor não
explica nada joga matéria no quadro no
fim o resultado esperado é reprovado
minha mãe se orgulha logo fica deprimido
infelizmente eu não fui o orgulho da
família na hora da lição eu ainda tiro
barato
digo que é uma vaca que está comendo no
pasto conteúdo programático é chato eu
fujo não sei a tabuada aprendia pular
muro para o campinense moleque com a 10
o vereador aqui
o noia viciado mas um fumador de crack
na cena principal são mais ampla de
giovanni o problema é que o governo não
investe na estudante
e gostaram de certa forma fez parte essa
parada estava a gente saiu muito para
fazer sair do beco finalizar assim a
responsabilidade é o termo que assinei
pra não falar besteira nas batidas do dj
mas não foi um papel que eu escrevi meu
nome é no meu sentimento que a letra se
consome princesa isabel a lei áurea
utopia cada rep que eu faça uma carta de
alforria liberto cada preso que está
dentro de uma cela
mostrando que para ele a liberdade é
muito bela não tem um raio gama errado
que eu não sei fazer por isso usou a
rima com o meu superpoder derrotando
inimigos que não acredita em nós você
que tá calado eu serei a sua voz são
estereótipos que prenda minha classe e o
suicídio da mentez um kamikaze vai para
a academia corpo belo é o sonho puxar
ferro livros e vou mandando neurônios
sacou a pistola atiradora de palavra e
as balas perdidas são as rimas na
quebrada e se que a violência fácil em
qualquer horário pois eu miro na cabeça
e atirou vocabulário poetas
contemporâneos que rebola bunda a mídia
que o poeta que tem uma boca muda olho
na vitrine retina consome marca é como
um cachorro além do frango na vidraça
não fala que a criança o futuro da nação
passa mais por ela sirva como inspiração
pois para cada carteira de cigarro que é
fumada no coração da tua coroa uma
punhalada você fuma eo capeta sorridente
que conduz
eu acho que o demônio o dono da souza
cruz respiração para destruir
conspiração não tem luz nem câmera mas
deu sua ação a nossa de cama não é prova
tão frisa frisa foco e sua camisa em
números 23 praça convocado e 200 milhões
esperam comida no prato nas periferias
logo quem espera nunca
ansa tem gente que vende o almoço para
comprar a janta princesas medievais
andavam a cavalo princesas de aba reta
só quer andar de camarão
não é questão de gênero que nós estamos
falando homens e mulheres eram porque
ambos são humanos e antes que as vielas
becos entra em coma eu quero ver os
moleques segurança diploma
bom só falar que essa é a nossa
contribuição protex várias pessoas
palestraram ea nossa forma de enviar
nossa mensagem através da música
muito obrigado tss crio obrigado